la caravane de François Legault fait le
détour par l'Hôtel de Ville de Lévis le
chef kakiste veut faire du maire un
allié pour son troisième lien merci de
ton appui sur le tunnel
même si le tunnel québé est réclamé par
bien les résidents ici il ne convainc
pas tous les contribuables québécois
auprès de qui il faut encore justifier
le projet de 6 milliards et demi de
dollars ça va aider le transport
collectif parce que ça va prendre 10
minutes
vont venir oui mais si ceux de favorable
au projet qu'est-ce que vous allez faire
je suis convaincu qu'ils vont être
favorable
le projet semble déjà loin des priorités
des citoyens plus à l'Est comme ceux de
Rivière-du-Loup et de Rimouski ou
François Legault s'est également rendu
là-bas il répète une fois de plus que
les études qu'il détient nuiront à
l'acceptabilité parce qu'une mise à jour
s'impose pourtant l'une d'entre elles
semble toujours actuelle c'était une
étude sur un lien à l'Est on parle
maintenant d'un lien centre-ville à
centre-ville l'étude en question est en
fait une revue des grands projets
d'infrastructures semblables au
troisième lien expliquant de manière
générale les impacts souvent observés
sur le développement résidentiel
commercial et agricole
mais il persiste ici hors de question de
présenter des études réalisées avant la
pandémie
au début 2023 on va la publier il y a
déjà entendu le projet avant même
d'avoir des études sur la pertinence du
projet c'est gênant tout ça est-ce que
c'est juste basé sur des maquettes les
études ont été payées par des fonds
publics rappellent ses adversaires il y
a 28 millions de dollars derrière ça on
sait toujours pas c'est quoi c'est
surtout le reflet de la manière de gérer
de François Legault même si la pression
s'accentue pour dévoiler les études
François Legault n'a pas l'intention
d'en faire une diversion dans sa
campagne surtout pas dans la région de
Québec où la course s'annonce série les
impacts du troisième seront connu
seulement après l'élection ici Véronique
prince Radio-Canada allez vie